[Music]
[Music]
don't hate sumo was it looking like how
many bedrooms do you want as HM oh four
five what sort of price do you want to
pay for HMO you guys are really good I'm
living this you know me tell you
something you know I I get it top I did
this this topic right now in London
about six months ago in front of a
roomful of I think there was like 750
people and there were all professional
investors you know very it would
consider some little full-time and I
said how much would an average HMO be
and they said around about 450 450 grand
I said how many rooms would it need and
they said five which was right I said
what does it need to be like and they
said it's gonna need a big drive for all
the cars that's it's gonna need a big
garden for whether people have barbecues
this is you're going to need five rooms
and they're all going to need on sweets
they said you're gonna need a real
special HMO mortgage which is really
hard to get and the interest rates are
really high on these types of mortgages
they said that I'm gonna need to do it
really either London or if not London
somewhere big like that like maybe
Birmingham what else did they say they
said that it helps if it's detached
basically a whole load of poo in fact
that Brian you you've heard that happen
haven't you in front of professional
full-time investors and they're just
like clueless clueless and you guys are
more advanced than that so I'm really
pleased but let me um let me break down
to you what a good hmm looks like so
firstly it doesn't have to be in London
or Birmingham when I started out my
first one was in Birmingham my second
one was in Birmingham and I kept buying
in Birmingham specifically in a little
place called Bournville had a builder
who told me that that was the only area
that HMOs worked
he said London's great because London is
buzzing everything but the
houses real expensive Birmingham the
North's cheap and tacky the South were
expensive with its lil plants called
Bournville hop on a train station you
can get there in about 20 minutes
ball mills the gold mine for HMOs I said
great so I was blindly HMOs in
vaudeville and then my friend bought one
in Wolverhampton I was like oh that's
like a good 45 minutes from Bournville
thinking that that isn't gonna work at
all
at the time I told you already I was
letting rooms remember and I was
marriage of people's women in bored
Ville and Healy said will you manage the
rooms of my property more Hampton I said
no I'm gonna struggle to rent them hang
all that Hampton no I said okay but
don't blame me when I can't work them
out
he said okay so I went around the house
him over happened to look around it was
alright I looked how much he paid for it
less than mining born all considerably
Pathak you paid a 86 grand for this
house four bedrooms ensuite some stuff
for mountain I put it on spare room and
my phone blew up and I rented the rooms
out in Wolverhampton faster than mine in
Bournville and I thought oh my goodness
there's two areas that work for HMOs in
the country
and then I realized that my builder had
lied to me
and in fact HMOs work well twice as loud
everywhere what I mean by everywhere
anywhere whereby there is a closed by
town or city center you will be able to
rent out rooms in that area there'll be
a demand why because HMO multi lakhs is
such a good product
some people say overwritten at rooms you
know I get accused of being tight trying
to spit but here's the thing right how
much does it cost to rent a cheap crummy
flat
in Birmingham 500 yeah cheap crummy flat
push bells how much the bells gonna be -
300
so - whereas let's say I have just
finished from London or Paris or
wherever or India to study in Birmingham
University on the birmingham university
student living in rented hall skin hall
i then graduate but i don't want to move
back to my place because I've fallen in
love and I've made friends and I've got
job offers I'm now 23 years old I'm in
Birmingham so I decided I mean I don't
want living student hall I'm not student
anymore so I'm gonna need to move
somewhere and I get my own place so
let's have a look at my options I can
either rent a crummy apartment in
Birmingham for five in Japan plus bills
750-800 a month or oh and also by the
way I'm gonna have to buy my furniture
I'm going to have to move it all in get
a removal van it's going to be a
freaking nightmare that's option one
option two is I can move into a nice
room that's nice with furniture really
handy to Birmingham Center or town pay
375 pounds or whatever for 350 400
anything even my wife I she professed in
the house I've got a communal living
area where I'm gonna get to hang out
with over the professionals and I got my
own bedroom and space which you're going
to choose crummy flat or room here we
choose a flat it's okay to use some
people which use a flat that's fine who
which is a room the bottom line is HMO
is a brilliant product and our tenant is
our customer and our house is our
product so that's why people are even
though HMOs oversaturated investors are
doing it and I feel like it's
oversaturated wake up start over
saturate it as more and more tenants
waking up to the fact but they can rent
rooms so the demand is getting bigger
yes the supply is getting bigger but the
demand is getting bigger so as long as
you can give people what they want
you can rent rooms really really well
[Music]